who wants to play body spotty spotties
so how do you play if you draw the piece
of paper that has the x on it you are
the murderer and if you're the murderer
you have to kill someone by touching
them on the back
the most important part if you come
across a body you have to yell
[Music]
set the lice which of us would be the
most likely to solve a murder
mystery
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
okay
what's everyone's favorite horror movie
to watch with friends
did we wash something together
jennifer's body did we watch his body no
but we watched that in the hotel room
together yeah that's a great one
jennifer's body's a great did we just
watch like a cassavetes
that was all right yeah yeah we were
assigned watching by helena yeah
you know
together
is that answering it no what's
everyone's kind of favorite horror movie
we gave two we have two yeah yeah
okay
[Music]
what was it like playing body's body's
bodies on set
and how did it bring you closer together
smacking we all saw each other oh that
oh
that made me feel so close to you guys
yeah we smacked each other for real for
one that's the most potent trust ball
yeah
yes yeah
yeah
they really did not want us to do that
and we insisted yeah we were all like
pdsm yeah
it's like i actually can't do this
unless i'm actually smacked yeah which
leads me to this there's a game in the
movie where we slap each other's faces
before taking a shot how did you prepare
for the game and what was it like
shooting that scene i mean we actually
slapped each other yeah it was quite fun
though i mean i thought it was fun it
was actually kind of hard to get the
to do the stage slap yeah
and they said that the real smack didn't
look like a real smack yeah yeah i said
it seemed weak in comparison yeah we
weren't hitting each other hard enough
yeah well we're gonna knock each other
out
i feel like pete and lee really went for
it they did yeah i heard we heard that
crap yeah that was unleashed really
stunning phase you don't remember that
he actually pete actually really
actually yeah pete lee asked him to i
remember that i was supposed to like
slap pete for real yeah i was feeling
really uncomfortable doing it yeah that
was very important
but i didn't know that actually he i
heard it was like i remember having a
real reaction
yeah no acting required right um
what was your favorite improv moment
while shooting the movie hmm i feel like
the scene outside in the rain the first
time we go in the rain yeah everyone
reacting was so like
it's kind of funny to watch now but it
was so like intense i was like everyone
on panic mode i was like okay this is
what everyone would look like if someone
died you know what i mean everyone was
full panic
yeah in a funny way but felt not funny
in the moment totally i actually really
enjoyed the improv you brought rachel to
the scene in the kitchen when she first
hits the fan
that one was that was kind of hard
because we were talking to each other
most of the time and you were adding
some i was like that's keep it together
because you made me want to defend
myself you really i needed to everyone's
like looking at me and like moving
around to the other side of the counter
yeah you go to the what all of a sudden
when you talk
you grab a knife and i'm like and
everyone's kind of like and you're like
like
and then i was like
everyone's against me that's when you
came up with like
you're silencing me yeah that was which
is like actually i get asked about that
line like quite often in interviews like
who came up with you're silencing me and
i was like
purely from the depths of rachel's
because it felt real and everyone it was
everyone against me i was like i need to
defend myself
so that was fun that was fun to be good
at body's buddies buddies you need to be
a good liar who's the best liar okay
on her backstabber who is a who is a
fake
who is the best at lying or keeping a
secret
oh keeping it i feel like those are a
bit too very they're not the same
this is true for literally all of
these people here i feel like i could
tell them anything and they would take
that [ __ ] to the grave yeah i feel like
even under pressure
like like chase would give an emma like
performance if i was like do not tell
anyone this i feel like you would take
that to the grave no matter what anyone
did to you you know what i mean that's
some real [ __ ] right there chase what's
a lie that you guys have told
one of us
on set is that a question or are you out
of pocket
i'm just fully stirring the pot
i don't remember think of it there's a
lie that i've told you guys i like
okay
you have one well i think we would
lie to each other like a white lie to
protect our feelings if it was some that
like we didn't need to know or that
wasn't neces you know what i mean like
if i had heard last take
you know
that
any time i felt uncomfortable i wore a
crop top and no way i really there were
times i lied during my costume fitting
because i didn't feel good and i was
like i'm bloated like i'm on my period
not on my period
it's like wow this girl is getting her
period six times
what do you think
five weeks yeah
okay that's really funny yeah i did that
[Laughter]
why why do you use that in the future
yeah
yeah no i'm gonna lean on that one
anytime i feel weird anytime i'm like
kind of acting not my best self anytime
you need some sympathy from yourself no
we should be yeah like because we
already have to deal with the peril of
having a period we should have the
privilege of just saying that we're
honored
that we have to say that we're going
through some sort of hormonal chemical
imbalance to justify how we feel yeah
feminism
what do you think older audiences
misunderstand about gen z
um that the language is not like
that the language is intentional it's
not like antiquated like they're just
like per girl like all of it has a
really specific and like
deep meaning that they just won't
understand you know and then yeah
yeah it's also like layered in so much
irony yeah yes yes yes they they ca
they're not with it i feel like people
think gen z is stupid they're so they're
they don't they don't have like a level
of sophistication or intelligence but i
actually think like they're really sweet
if anything the level of sophistication
and sarcasm and intelligence gets in the
way of like emotional wealth yes
um
[Music]
or like they think if you're on your
phone like
you are doing the most vapid
like yeah work is not meaningful or you
can't hear like you can still talk to me
if my if i'm looking at my my mom my mom
bless her she does the thing she goes oh
are you
and she stops and i'm like what's up and
she's like no no i'll wait i'm like oh
my gosh mama it's okay i can hear you
also like twitter is the news like
twitter is yeah that's true like the
cultural consciousness yeah twitter is
the new name i'm at the office when i'm
on my phone
um who's turn maria
besides body's body's bodice what's your
favorite 824
should i grab movie examples yeah but
are there something go ahead they have
everything everywhere all at once oh
that's updated
also
green room i love green i love the
lobster i want to see that my answer is
bling ring oh my god ring ring is so
classic
the opening of that movie when crown on
the ground starts playing you see
they're running into thousands
and it's like purse shoe
got girl i was like this is my this is
what i want to do with the rest of my
life this movie
yeah eat hot chip and lie and they also
have they also have two one two three
yeah oh yeah iconic rendition of yeah
red rocket oh very good
i think just for
the times i have to say everything
everywhere all at once yeah yeah that
was truly
deeply and inspiring reinvigorating so
fresh
certified fresh that movie made me
so that my friends are excited about
about filmmaking yeah
i'm gonna do authentication the the
design of it all the design elements i
thought they really like they were like
we're gonna make it all the colors and
all the shapes we're gonna do all these
absurdist things that actually was like
so charming and somehow grounding and i
really appreciated that creativity i
thought that was so genius
uh what was your favorite part about
working with helena wayne and how did
she keep this film both intense and fun
everything about helene is intense and
fun yeah yeah for real i feel like
helena does this amazing thing that
maybe you guys all can relate to like
she changes her the way she gives
direction she changes her face and her
body and because she's such a skilled
actress herself
like you understand there's like a
shorthand to her notes because she
immediately like
can embody like each of our characters
and it's so brilliant like the way that
just like you immediately okay like i
can latch on to that like no words are
needed yeah yeah and i feel like she's
like totally wild and absurd and then
and then like grounded and caring at the
same yeah in equal measure yeah
yeah and she wants you to i think she's
so free as a person that she inspires
you to be free like there's like and
this is kind of similar to what you're
saying but it's like she's in the mud
with you like she's in the rain
she's like literally out there being
like girls like yes
and you're like
you're on you're with us you're in the
movie with us yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like she'll just like
like during that party sequence like
she'll just like grab you and like start
dancing like she like and she just gets
right in it like yeah
crawling also really really really
trusted us like she had a level of
respect
and admiration for what we could do so
that when we came to the set she was
like i trust you um take this wherever
you want to take it like bring your own
ideas
she allowed us to collaborate with the
script and with her and you know what i
mean in that level of trust i think
especially as a young actor um
sometimes it feels like you like you
have to prove yourself i never once felt
that with helena which gives you so much
freedom again is another word we're
gonna say about
yeah she was incarnated yeah she became
a part of us she became like
yeah the seventh the sixth girl yeah
yeah she gave birth to us i think
we all came out of her vagina yep
yeah the movie required a lot of night
shoots who is the best night owl and do
you have any special tricks to stay
awake uh jumping jacks is always my
nighttime
go-to really
we had you never saw me doing dummy
ducks i did but i didn't know if that's
what it was he said i gotta stay awake
yeah i was like i gotta stay away i
gotta act like i just ran through
freaking windstorm
we had that one night when like we were
bracing ourselves for a literal um
uh full overnight storm yeah and we just
needed a morale boost and we all were
like just started blasting the most
ridiculous music and just had like a 30
minute dance party and like our heating
pads and like yeah right before we're
about to get
thrown out in the freezing blood cold
that was really good that was a good
thing it was also early only early odds
hits like only throw out yeah only
average yeah
okay i somehow did not know that that
was the the hurricane warning
what do you mean it wasn't realized no
was that what that was no i think oh
okay okay
oh okay i think yeah that was that
wasn't the night that we were okay
oh because you said right now you're
done for the storm i was like was that
when that was happening and we were just
like la la la to kelly clarks
oh okay okay okay yes we were sheltering
down for many storms
yeah but that was that specific night
when it was only uh
yeah yeah yeah only got all the chairs
prepared and everybody had a bottle yeah
that was supposed to heat up yeah and
the whole thing was so freaking scared
for us yeah yeah everybody was like oh
god they're going to be out there yeah
right now yeah i can't helena also going
my actresses are cold
i remember yeah
my girls are cold my girls are cold
um wait guys i have a good one
i completely lost the order and i'm
asking no it's you but this is other
than a mansion where would be the most
fun place to play bodies buddies bodies
oh my gosh
uh in public maybe
like surrounded by
people so they could observe
people lying dead on the ground
i don't know i could cause panic maybe
like on a beach
a remote island a theme park oh that's a
good one yes yeah sequel in the room a
boat
the perfect
who here do you think would be most
likely to win the hunger games once
again i'm going to say my holla yeah
yeah
you know
i thought maybe you might
but
that requires killing does it not
no you could be literally you could
there's a hideout if you make yourself
look like a rock do you remember that's
right that's what people are saying you
just kind of are like very resourceful
yeah like literally camouflages his
whole body it is laying there for half
the game like next to a room literally
okay i'll take that one i could be a
rock chicken
anybody got any good ones on there we
yeah let's do it we have one more
question
what about what do you think is the best
question to ask to trip someone up when
playing body's buddy's bodies oh
that's hard i feel like like why are you
lying is a good one oh god that's so
incredible anxiety inducing that's so
crazy the way someone flinches could
tell you a lot you should be yeah why
are you lying
just like i think you're like asking for
anyone's alibis
yeah yeah yes that's so true like so all
right why aren't you killer right yeah
because also once you start to describe
you're like well i was upstairs and then
i went and it's like it sounds like a
lie yeah
oh or another one
why would i do this and then everyone
else starts talking about it and then
you don't even have to say it's true the
deflection tactic the deflection is
pretty good do i look like a killer yeah
you